i want to start today by talking about a
new statement from the cdc
about coronavirus vaccination of younger
people
and what appears to be a link to a very
rare uh
heart condition which can also be caused
by the virus itself and
i think i i feel driven to
kind of preface this by saying on the
one hand i've been a huge advocate of
vaccination and continue to be and this
doesn't change that
and so for people who will react to me
talking about this by saying are you
going anti-vaccine
absolutely not uh the risks of this
condition with the vaccine are far lower
than the risks of the very same
condition if you get coveted
on the other hand for people who have
been saying david you won't ever
talk about the side effects of vaccines
well you're also wrong because i'm
talking about them
right here so let's get right into it
um cdc safety group says there's a
likely link
between rare heart inflammation in young
people
after covid shot there have been more
than twelve hundred cases
of a myocarditis or pericarditis mostly
in thirty and under people who received
pfizer's
or modernist covid19 vaccine according
to cdc data
roughly 300 million shots had been
administered as of june 11th
for both vaccines combined there were 12
heart inflammation cases per million
doses the cdc safety group is calling it
a likely association between this rare
heart inflammatory condition in
adolescents and young adults
mostly after they've received their
second shot
based on the most recent data available
twelve hundred
cases according to a series of
presentations published yesterday
wednesday
myocarditis is the inflammation of the
heart muscle
pericarditis is the inflammation of the
membrane surrounding
the heart dr grace lee chairs the cdc
safety group says
clinical presentation of myocarditis
cases following vaccination
has been distinct occurring most often
within one week after dose
two with chest pain as the most common
presentation um information is being
gathered
about how to manage this the agency said
there have been 267 cases of myocarditis
or pericarditis after one dose
and 827 after two doses
132 additional cases where doses
received
is unknown importantly dr
tom shimabukuro says this is still a
rare event
it's mostly men under 30. remember the
blood clotting with the jnj was mostly
women under 45 this is mostly men under
30.
very important of the 295 people who
developed the condition and have been
discharged
79 fully recovered nine were
hospitalized
two in intensive care so there's no
reason to hide this we want to
understand
the risks and uh understand any
medication treatment or whatever that
that we are obtaining
when you look at these numbers you're
talking about out of 300 million doses
two people in intensive care and so we
should be aware of this
as a vaccination sites uh are told about
this and
develop protocol for managing it this is
why you
have all of this data and do this
research the vaccine
is still way safer at all ages than
getting coveted that's an important
thing to remember
we now know i know personally of people
of a variety of ages 25 plus
dying of covid i know of one person with
an allergic reaction to the vaccine
that was sort of serious she was brought
to the er
and was fine after a couple of hours
there's no reason to hide this stuff
it looks bad to hide it it should be
reported in proper context
and remember that covet itself
comes with risk of heart inflammation
and it's a really important thing
uh to remember so information is still
being gathered about this
it's extraordinarily rare and
even in almost all cases where this rare
thing happens
people make a full recovery those are
the facts as we understand them
right now and as more information comes
forward about this of course
i will present it to you